bill cosby has now spent his first 24
hours in prison it's just the start of
his 3 to 10 year sentence and we want to
give you a glimpse of what his life will
be like behind bars after yesterday's
sullen mugshot Cosby posed for a new one
in Prison Blues et obtained his booking
sheet once known as America's TV dad now
he's simply inmate number NN 7 687 @ s
CI Phoenix Pennsylvania's most expensive
prison
the 81 year old who is legally blind was
house near the infirmary in a single
cell with no cellmate authorities tell
us quote the long-term goal is general
population life for this celeb behind
bars means no special treatment because
he was labeled a sexually violent
predator Cosby must attend sex offender
counseling he is however allowed
visitors and phone calls and can choose
to exercise standard for most inmates
his first meal per the prison menu we
obtained meatballs with green beans and
potatoes during lunchtime tomorrow
they're serving jello which Cosby once
promoted today's specialist jell-o
gelatin jigglers the big question now is
will this be his home for three to ten
years according to the DEA Cosby may
move to a prison for lower risk inmates
I'll get designated to one of the state
institutions throughout the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania it's tough
Starr's reacted to Cosby's fall from
grace at BET's q85 celebration for
quincy jones it's shocking but it would
have been more shocking to not see
anything happen hopefully things will
get better for everyone that's been
abused and how about this Celts OJ
Simpson weighed in on Cosby's
incarceration OJ said the Cosby should
be put in protective custody because
quote rapists are frowned upon in prison
[Music]
[Applause]